well thank you Mr President shrink
flation now apparently coming for our
Oreos fans of the iconic cookie are
fuming at the company and a new Wall
Street Journal headline is explaining
why quote the biggest shrinkflation
Scandal yet Oreo fans think cookies have
less fing Say It Ain't So the maker of
Oreos denies tinkering with the amount
of cream filling but some say double
stuff Oreos are not what they used to be
Greg I'm not even sure I can see this
thin layer of cream in my Oreo yeah the
white stuff is missing they has anybody
checked with Hunter oh my gosh but uh
you know their F the Oreo fans grew
suspicious when they suddenly uh felt
healthier why isn't a candidate for
president running with this issue Chris
Christie should get in front of this you
know here the deal here's the deal if
they are cutting costs why skimp on the
white stuff it's the best part of the
cookie the why the double stuff sells so
well but under Joe Biden's America they
hate everything
white I guess that's why the white white
filling is now s his domestic teror
yourid is more identity politics Jess
they're going after the white filling
this is how Trump wins 22% of the black
vote if these are this big yeah he's
going to get it I judge look at that
that there is barely any white I am an
Oreo cookie connoisseur
all right I do three packages a day all
right I do it's sick there's something
wrong with me although Peppermint
Patties are my favorite but anyway the
all you taste now is just the outside
cracker it's like you don't even taste
the sugar and the cream on the inside
anymore so I can testify as an expert
that they have reduced the amount of the
sweetest part of the Oreo I was
surprised this was about the double
stuff Oreos so I fully transitioned my
announcement to double stuff Oreos and
the golden ones mm so I've gone extra
white actually in all of this um are you
changing your
pronoun a chunky and chunkier um no I I
don't know if I believe I feel like
they're the same or at least the ones
that I'm having are the same how do you
eat well I get when you get the double
stuffed golden pack it's like the four
huge rows so I mean my husband and I can
Crush in an evening if a good night I'm
not a big Oreo fan I will say but I mean
the broader Point here is you open a bag
of chips and it's like half full I go to
the grocery store I swear $24 for a pack
of chickens and they say inflation has
come down but people are not feeling it
and if people don't feel it it's bad
well it's funny I I actually noticed it
myself but I just thought it was some
sort of new kind of cookie like it was
like a thinner Oreo and they have a th
they they they were they were fine but
whatever but you but you can't lie about
it and like when when Joe Biden talks
about the economy and he talks about how
there's this disconnect between the
great economy that I'm giving America
and the the terrible economy everybody
feels it's like dude that's not a
disconnect it's a lie and you're telling
it and you you can't when it Oreos can't
tell the LIE any better than but you
know the good news is uh he actually
admitted he said finally I understand
people don't feel the numbers oh you
have we have that let's
play I acknowledge there's a disconnect
between the numbers and how people feel
about their place in the world right now
we can deal with the second part as well
we still have work to do but our model
for growing is delivering Real Results
for all
Americans you never know if it's over or
he just pausing you know but no but the
truth is they he's he's got to
understand what is it 69% 70% are not
happy with the economy it may even be
higher 80% and so they finally said to
them Joe you got to go out there and
tell the people you feel what they feel
took months but he finally kind of
admitted it but it's still insulting cuz
he's sitting here saying that there's a
disconnect as if his his story is not a
lie his story is a
lie can we get back to the topic of
Oreos for God's sake here's my solution
here's my solution you should have make
your own Oreos where you come with a
little stack of the Wafers and you get a
little tub of the white the white and
you can yourself can buy icing in a that
way right
I will say Jessica to to the point of
the economy just quickly you know that
people aren't feeling it I remember
being at CNN on a panel and a Democrat
holding up a newspaper right before
Donald Trump was elected saying the
economy is great if only these numbers
got out there the bottom line is that
people don't feel it as the president
acknowledges I mean about 30 days later
Donald Trump was elected after that
moment yeah 100% um I I have said that
he should be talking about this from the
jump you want to talk about your
policies but you also want to be the
empathizer in Chief but there has been a
bit of a turn we've seen On's happened
prices of eggs milk gas across the
country and now in the new yugov poll
his approval or biomics or handling of
the economy went up to 46% now do you
want that over 50% 100% that's a lot of
percentages I threw out but it used to
be below 40% so usually when things are
turning around it takes about six months
to a year for people to fully be
emphasizing it in terms of polling but
it does seem like he's been how long has
he been in yeah long time that's a long
time two yeah and word of warning to
Republicans the economy didn't really
translate too well in the midterm so
that's do you think this is an
impeachable offense yes the Oreo I think
we need to do
that open
tomorrow all right well up next rap
Legends Snoop Dog shocking the world
after announcing he is giving up hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else